randall kennedy when i was growing up
my mother said never use this word
how am i going to get through this
interview with you
well i'm not sure how you're going to
get this through this interview maybe
you can
use the word and mentally put quotation
marks around it i'm sure i'm not the
first person that said that to you
well with this book yeah there's a lot
of
wonderment about how to talk about this
particular book
uh if i calculate calculated all right
you're you're saint albans
graduate yes is that both grade school
and high school
i went to st albans uh 8th through 12th
grades
and i might add that it's the the best
school i've ever been to
in washington same school that al gore
went to the same school that al gore
went to yes
you're a graduate of princeton yes
you're an oxford
rhodes scholar yes you're a graduate of
yale law school
clerk to thurgood marshall and now teach
at the harvard law school yes what are
you doing writing a book with this title
i'm writing a book with this title
because um
[ __ ] is a very powerful provocative
word
that is
provides a very interesting window on
american culture
why well it's a word that
first of all has an interesting history
it certainly takes
us it's a it's a fascinating word
i mean it's a
first and foremost a slur
that provides
a window on some of the ugliest aspects
of american history
but it's not simply a slur it is a
word that meek that means
many things it's been used in an ugly
way as a
as a weapon but it's also a word
that has been used as a term of
endearment
it is a word that has been used as an
anti-racist
weapon so it's an interesting word and
that's why
i found it worthwhile to spend my time
and energy writing a book about it
where did you get the idea
i think the thing that provoked me to
write the book was a couple
of years ago on an afternoon
i was just working at my desk
and in my i teach a class on
race relations law and in that class i
often
build lectures around key words so
discrimination
or racism anyway i was thinking about
key words in american race relations and
the word [ __ ] popped into my head
and i was at my desk i put [ __ ] into
the lexus nexus
computer database
and i put in the commands to bring up
any case
that included the word [ __ ] any
federal case or any state case
and thousands of cases came up the
citation list
was a couple of thousand
and then i i got the list the citation
list and i just started
reading through the cases and after
doing that for a couple of days
i had the sense that i was really onto
something that i could
actually group these cases together
see what the various controversies were
and have an interesting narrative on my
hands
you also plugged in other words i did i
plugged in other words i mean as i
developed this once i got the idea of
writing about uh [ __ ]
um as i started developing lectures
i thought well i mean this word is not
the only racial slur what about others
and so i started popping in others to
see
what other words well [ __ ] was a word
[ __ ]
was a word uh [ __ ] was a word
[ __ ] [ __ ] but nothing came close
nothing came close to [ __ ] in the
number
of citations in court cases or for that
matter
in magazine or newspaper articles
well it turns out that you have one of
the few african-american
editors that edited this book i
understand what's his name
his name is errol mcdonald and i say one
of the few because that's the way that
newspapers have described it why are
there only a few
from your experience i'm not sure
frankly
i'm not sure why there's so few uh
african americans in what i would
describe as elite publishing the new
york
elite publishing world he is
one of their very few he's edited other
books that i've written
and he was very supportive of this
venture what was his reaction though
when you first called him
well i actually i did i sent him the
manuscript
i just i just sent him the manuscript
and
uh i heard uh through uh
my agent that uh he was very
enthusiastic
about the project and that was and that
was that
then the publicity started i mean you
got a major piece in the new york times
on december the first
long before the book was even bound
what was your reaction i mean for
instance they started a black author
hurls that word
as a challenge and one of the first
people they quote in here is julian
malveaux who is in your book also quoted
she says i don't think its use is taking
the sting out of it i think it's
escalating at this point
you are just giving a whole bunch of
races who love to use the word
permission to use it
even more like i'm really not using it
and she says i'm just talking about a
book
well she's got a point i i don't i i
don't
doubt that there will be people
who will use this book in the way that
she
suggests as a excuse as a cover
as permission to use [ __ ]
in very hurtful ways that's true
or at least that's that's what i think
will happen uh
hopefully that um
consequence of this book will
be superseded by another consequence i
think that a lot more people a lot more
readers
will be enlightened by the book uh will
will develop a sensitivity that they
might not have had before
i think there will be readers who will
be strengthened by the book
so anytime you write about something
provocative
there's a danger in fact probably
anytime you write anything
uh there is a danger writing is a
dangerous enterprise
but hopefully uh the good will
out distance the bad do you have any
idea how many copies pantheon's
printing on the first printing i don't
any range i mean normally do you know
what
size books you do 20 000
my sense is probably about 20 000. yeah
that
that's what i would think would be
published
you talk about a person in the book by
the name i believe david howard
yes from washington d.c what's that
story and julian
malveaux wasn't happy about that
situation either
that's right uh that was a k one of the
chapters in the book
is uh about what i think to be
um pitfalls in fighting the word [ __ ]
and so i devote a chapter to
uh episodes in which
uh people were angry about
what they perceived to be a racial
insult so what happened in this the case
that you mentioned
a white fella a white official in
washington d.c
used the term niggered lee
and some colleagues heard
him use the word niggeredly and
thought erroneously that niggeredly
was related to [ __ ] was an offshoot of
[ __ ] so they said well
what did you say and he said niggerly
they were insulted there was a
whispering campaign
that was loosed against him
and eventually he this whispering
campaign became such a big deal
that he felt that he had to tender his
resignation to the mayor of washington
d.c who accepted his resignation
this got out to the papers and for a
couple of weeks there was a big human
cry
about about this episode
niggerly has very different roots than
[ __ ]
and so part of the hue and cry had to do
with a sense that you know uh people
simply weren't being careful enough
or this was sort of a
just an ignorant mistake that people
were making i think the part of the
human cry had to do with the sense that
people were being overly sensitive
in any event i described the dynamics
around this particular
episode and suggest that this was a this
was a case where people were being
um just too quick on the trigger there
was two
it was it was too quick uh too ready
a willingness to be wounded to be hurt
julian malveaux who is a black economist
columnist says i have a bunch of
dictionaries and i understand that
niggeredly and niggling
are not the same as the n word but i am
still annoyed amazed outdone by howard
meaning david howard he understands that
perhaps there are other ways to indicate
a tightness and budget that one might
say parsimonious frugal or
miserly no matter how many times
teutonics
attempts to trump ebonics the fact is
that the n word
be it the n word or negatively rankle
well i mean as a sociological matter
she's right
in the sense that there were a number of
people of various hues by the way not
just black people people i've talked
with
white people too there were white
columnists too who suggested that he
should have used a different word
maybe he should have used a different
word uh but the point was or at least
my position in the book was this man
should not have lost
his job over
the use of a word especially in so far
as he explained
what he was up to i mean he said well i
certainly didn't intend to hurt
anybody's feelings the word niggerly is
different than the word [ __ ]
once that came out
people should have backed off uh
and maybe mr howard the next time around
would use the word the parsimonious
instead of niggerly
knowing that there might be someone
close by
who might get the wrong impression of
the word he was using what eventually
happened to him
well eventually he got his job back i
don't know if he's still in the dc
government but there was uh
there was a lot of controversy i think
the mayor felt
embarrassed about having so quickly
accepted his resignation he was offered
his as his position back
and i think he went back into the
government again he might have left it
i'm not sure ultimately what happened
but he was offered his job back
has the word ever been used the word
that describes this the title of your
book ever been used
at you yes when was the first time you
can remember it
i don't remember the first time it was
used the fact of the matter is
this is a word that has been with me
throughout my life
i probably heard it i'm from columbia
south carolina the first time i heard
the word [ __ ] was
probably in my house with relatives
using the word [ __ ]
i've heard the word [ __ ] used in many
many different ways
it has been directed at me in
a loving way in an ironic way
in a hurtful a hateful way
i've heard the word [ __ ] used in
across the spectrum of ways what about
in a hurtful way when was that
well in a variety of instances um
the first day that i went to boston
the first day that i went to boston i
flew to logan airport
uh took a cab to the
harvard law school in the tunnel
the cab that i was driving in uh
cut in front of another cab driver
these two cab drivers they were driving
but
clearly through their their windows
there was there was some sort of uh
altercation between them verbal
altercation the guy in the back
white cab driver um rolls down his
window sticks his head out the window
and starts
cursing not on at not only the driver of
my cab who was black
but it me as well i turned around and
looked him dead in the eye
and he was talking about [ __ ] this and
[ __ ] that
that was an instance there have been
many others in oxford you mentioned i
was an oxford in oxford
i remember
on a sunday getting up really early
walking down
high street in oxford it's minding my
own business
car comes up beside me a guy rose
rolls down the window says
[ __ ] go home so i've had various
experiences uh
with with the n-word you you point out
that
the president united states can use a
phrase
that begins with an a and it ends with
whole
yes about an individual but cannot if eu
and get elected president but if you use
the n word
no way that's right because uh
the n word has been thoroughly
stigmatized in american culture any a
politician
cannot no no politician can be elected
president of the united states if he
is uh captured on tape
uh using the word [ __ ] i would i would
set that forth as a
just as a ironclad proposition and i
think it's a good thing
uh i think that uh if he's used well let
me let me back up a moment
if he's using that term
in a way that
that bespeaks either enmity
or that bespeaks indifference
or contempt he cannot be elected
president
of the united states and that's a good
thing
well what about the reverse of that
though because you're talking about the
instance
or the incident during the campaign when
george bush and dick cheney were
standing on the stage and referring to a
new york times reporter adam climber
and he called him the uh
a h word right uh how come that didn't
hurt
well that's just a different word and i
think people as it's a different word
it has different connotations it's a
word
that doesn't have the history doesn't
have the baggage
uh that uh that the n word
uh has uh again the the
[ __ ] is a word that
has a very violent history
i mean there are many instances in the
book where i talk about
the uh violent episodes
i mean it's it's it's a word that um
has violence it has blood uh
around it it's a word that
in many instances justly causes fear
it's a menacing word and so it has
connotations
that uh are different than
just your regular sort of curse word
were you ever called this by any of your
classmates in any of those places you
went to school
i had a very interesting episode at uh
at saint albans school explain what save
always is saint albans school
is a an all-boys school it's a private
school in the district of columbia
it is a absolutely fabulous school
the best school not only that i've
attended the best school that i've ever
seen and i've been at some very fine
institutions
connected with the national cathedral it
is on the grounds of the national
cathedral
it is the school that i attended from
8th grade to 12th grade
it's the school that really gave me
my education and
it is the school that
the education i got at st albans is a is
an education that i go to
time and time again for instance this
book is called
[ __ ] the strange career of a
troublesome
word when i was a student at saint
albans school i read the strange career
of jim crow
by steven woodward and so
the very subtitle of this book is yet
another vestige of the education that i
got at st
albans in any event i i i don't want to
go on and on about saint albans it's
just that uh
it it's a it's such a fine school and
has meant so much
to me and continues to mean so much to
me in any event when i was at st
albans i had a when i was in 12th grade
uh i was kidding around with a black
classmate actually
in the library and this black classmate
and there were very few black other
black students there were maybe five
black students in my class of 70.
in any event this class mate at one
point we were just sort of joshing back
and forth and he
he called he he called me [ __ ]
and what was sort of interesting was
that there were some white classmates
around us
and i felt
that i was i was a i was the president
of the student body
and i felt that i could not allow this
to go by the boards and so i said
if you call me that again i'm going to
give you demerits on the spot
and i think he was sort of taken aback
by that and he caught and he said
[ __ ] again and i said well i'll see
you here saturday
i gave him the merits and we spent
saturday morning together at saint
albans school
that was an episode that
i had actually forgotten about until i
started writing this book
did you ever hear the word at princeton
not that i can think of offhand and what
was your living environment there
uh i was i lived four years on the
campus at uh at princeton surrounded by
all sorts of people but live in a dorm
oh i lived in the dorms yeah i lived in
the dorms for four years
and i can't think of a
an episode i can't think of a time when
i heard somebody use the word [ __ ] at
least
now i should use the word [ __ ] uh as
uh an insult now again i've been
throughout our conversation thus far
i've been we've been
hearkening back to [ __ ] as insult and
of course that's a very
large part of the the history of the
word
on the other hand one of the things that
makes [ __ ] interesting
is that it's not simply an insult it is
also
used amongst black people
as a term of endearment
as a it's it's sort of turned on its
head
it's used ironically now i can't help
but think
that during my time at princeton
i must have heard the word [ __ ] used
in its you know as a term of endearment
or its ironic
use with other black students what does
it mean and where does it come from
in terms of just in general yeah
well i mean what what's the what's the
where does that actual
word come from the way the word is
derived from
niger which was latin for black
um and
how it actually became an insult is
unclear the
random house dictionary of american
slang
has a very nice treatment of [ __ ] as
does the oxford english dictionary
and both of those dictionaries take the
word
back to the 17th century
so i mean it's got a long lineage but
one of the interesting things about the
word is initially
it was not used apparently as a slur
how it actually became a slur is unclear
we do know though that by the early
um 19th century certainly by the 1830s
it was a very
well slur by the 1830s the word [ __ ]
was first of all was prevalent and it
was
well known as a as a slur how it
actually got that way
not all together you do have a case
though in the book uh from 1997 in
ypsilanti michigan
yes story about the merriam-webster's
collegiate dictionary
yes um one of the controversies
surrounding [ __ ] is the question of
well how should it be defined
webster's dictionary had a definition
in which had a definition in which uh
the
[ __ ] and i think
i've got it well read it really a black
person
this is taken to be offensive second
definition a member of any dark-skinned
race
taken to be offensive and third a member
of a socially disadvantaged class of
persons
uh it's time for somebody to lead all
americans
i didn't understand this all all the
people who feel left out of the
political process
dash ron dellums i guess that's an
example
yeah uh it says usages and senses one
and two can be found in the works of
such
writers past as joseph conrad mark twain
charles dickens
but it uh it uh now ranks as perhaps the
most offensive and inflammatory racial
slur in english
but this person and i'm not sure i
pronounced this phrase it delphini
i'm not sure abraham from epsilon
michigan contacted john morris
president publisher of merriam-webster's
collegiate dictionary and was not not
happy about this and what happened
she was not happy about it because she
thought that the dictionary was not
accentuating enough uh the the
um the derogatory um
aspect of the word because the first uh
the they said [ __ ] uh a black person
and she thought well you know this is
this makes it seem as though the word's
okay this makes it seem as though the
word is simply a synonym for a black
person
of course that's not exactly that's not
really what the
dictionary said the dictionary went out
of its way just listen to what you just
said the dictionary went out of its way
to say this is a derogatory word it's an
offensive word
it may be the most offensive word in the
english language
she thought that that should have been
first that that that
the offensiveness the derogatory nature
of the word
there should have been sort of a big
underlining of that
and only after that was stated should
they have said
it's you know used against black people
so at any event she wanted the
dictionary to
uh change the way they had just
the the dictionary described the word
define the word
the dictionary did not change it so she
wrote to the uh she wrote to a number of
magazines
she wrote to the naacp the national
association for the advancement of
colored people
ultimately she said
that this dictionary should be the
subject of
a boycott and
the dictionary actually the officials of
the dictionary
created a committee they did ultimately
change their definition to some extent
in their next edition um and she wasn't
and she and others were not completely
happy with
the the sort of the new definition that
was given
i wonder if there's a contrast here
because you say that quizzium fume
who heads up the naacp said to start a
boycott
yeah contrast that with roy wilkins who
is the head of the naacp
and his attitude toward the amos and
andy television and radio show
years later that's not quite the same
thing but i mean it was
there's a whole different attitude about
how to deal with it well it's sort of
interesting
um i do i talk about amos and andy amos
and andy was a
show first on radio that on television
that uh it was it was it was a comedy
show
and it was a comedy show that's that was
about
black characters the black characters
initially were actually
two white men who were playing black
characters
later when amos and andy went to
television the
the characters were actually black
actors
well amos and andy was a very
controversial show
some blacks thought that amos and andy
was
um was a show that put black people down
and um there were some black people that
uh wanted to boycott and in fact did
boycott amos and andy and urge other
people to boycott amos and andy write to
the
people who advertised on amos and andy
and tell them about their dislike
for amos and andy um early on
interestingly enough roy wilkins who
later became the head of the naacp
but in the 1930s and 1940s when he was a
newspaper man
roy wilkins uh
voiced displeasure with those who wanted
to boycott amos and andy
in fact he said amos and andy is a
perfectly okay show
in fact black actors and black comedy
writers should try to duplicate
the success of amos and andy later when
he became the president
of the naacp he
uh argued in favor of a boycott
of amos and andy and in fact was helpful
and
or he was instrumental in getting amos
and andy yanked
from its position uh on um from its
place
on network television it was quite a
surprise to me because i
grew up watching them that they were
only on two years
they were only on for amos and andy was
actually only on for two years
though on television though for several
years afterwards
it ran uh on reruns and was as a re-run
show
it was uh very popular so i think most
people think of amos and andy as
having had a life on tv that would that
was significantly longer than two years
what's your own position
on use of the n word my own position is
a complicated position
i mean as a person not not as a theory
but
how do you use it in your own life in my
own life um
in my own life there are have do i
ever use the n word yes i do
if i'm recounting uh jokes
there are a number of uh comedians
whom i admire quite a lot
who uh use the n-word one of my
favorite albums comedy albums
there's an album by richard pryor called
that nigger's crazy
i talk about that album in my book
i repeat i have repeated on many
occasions
jokes from that nigger's crazy
i think that that album is a wonderful
album that tells us a lot about black
american culture
a lot about american race relations
it is a as far as i'm concerned one of
the treasures of
american culture and um
i i think that it is part of our
cultural inheritance
i use it i have repeated jokes from it
i like another instance would be
mark twain's huckleberry finn
i have talked about uh
i've i've repeated what mark twain had
to say
about in huckleberry finn mark twain
uses [ __ ] on over 200 occasions in
huckleberry finn
um so do i
have i repeated the word have i used the
word
yeah i've used it i don't think i don't
use it as a term
of um uh i don't i don't use it as a
as a word to wound people i don't use it
as a
word of racial put down
but uh do i think
that the word [ __ ] has a place in
american culture the answer would be yes
chris rock is another comedian that you
talk about yes uses it a lot
yes successful let me ask you about this
though sinbad
now i may be wrong about this i've
watched i've watched him on several
occasions
never swears never uses this word
and never tells a dirty joke and looks
to me
to be hugely popular he is and i like
sinbad
and that's fine and that's great but
what would be more popular
say in the black community only tough to
tell remember
one of the points i make the black
community first of all is many
communities
it's not one big monolith with people
thinking the same thing the fact of the
matter is
uh when uh they're gonna
they're gonna be lots of different views
of my books
of my book among black people what's
bill cosby going to say
bill cosby whom i respect a great deal
is not going to like my book um
or at least he's not going to like large
portions of the book i hope that he
likes the book
but they're going to be certain
positions that i take in the book that
he's not going to like for instance bill
cosby
believes that black comedians should
never
use uh [ __ ] uh
in their jokes he thinks that it's a
very bad thing
to use [ __ ] in entertainment
and so he would like sinbad's
you know never using the word [ __ ] and
he would be profoundly critical
of black comedians who do use the word
[ __ ] especially the younger ones
that use the word [ __ ] actually quite
a lot
and i defend the use of the word [ __ ]
in jokes not i mean
my position with the word [ __ ] is it
all depends it all depends on how
somebody's using it because
[ __ ] like every other word
is uh takes its
its meaning from the circumstances you
know you can
insult somebody calling them sir
i can insult you by calling you sir it
all depends on how i use the word sir
it all depends on the inflection of my
voice it all depends on
the the the other words that surround
my use of the word sir so
[ __ ] it all depends on how you use it
it can be
you can you can assault assault somebody
with it
but you can also embrace somebody with
it out
front in this book you have a dedication
to it's hard to read but there are lots
of names
this book is dedicated to the board
and that's gary e bell chairman for life
who is gary ebell
gary e bell is my
first cousin he lives in columbia south
carolina
and he is the chairman of a group of
people
that we call the board they are mainly
my cousins
although there are some there are some
others as well and this book is
dedicated
to that group of people people
these are these are my cousins these are
dear friends of
ours mainly located in
south carolina which is where i come
from
and these are people who have guided me
throughout my life
gary bell is the self-appointed
chairman for life and his reign has not
been challenged by the other members of
the board how old is he
gary is probably a man in his
early 50s what's he do gary bell
is a certified public accountant he
has been a um public servant
in the state of south carolina he's
taught in the state of south carolina
uh how's he related to he's my first
cousin
which way though i'm sorry he is he his
his
his mom is my mother's
sister there's also a henry h kennedy jr
on this list
henry h kennedy jr is my older brother
uh henry h kennedy jr is a united states
district judge
here in the district of columbia he
was a
judge on the d.c superior court in fact
i think he was the youngest
judge ever on the d.c superior court he
was appointed to that court when he was
only 31 years old who appointed him he
was appointed
to that court by jimmy carter i believe
he was appointed to the united states
district court by
bill clinton before that he was
a united states an assistant united
states attorney
and who is angela s kennedy a cree
angela s
kennedy akery is my younger sister she
too
is an attorney uh she works for the
public defender service
in washington uh d.c so they're
my my younger sister my older brother
and myself were all lawyers we all went
to princeton by the way
so how did all this happen i mean go
back to mom and dad
my mother is uh
was a retired school teacher
she she taught at chevy chase elementary
school
for over a quarter of a century i'm
running in the dc area i'm always
running into people
who were taught by taught by my mother
at
chevy chase elementary school my father
is a retired
postal clerk he was a mail carrier a
male
handler for over a quarter of a century
he's from
baton rouge louisiana my mother is from
columbia south carolina
they are
very hard driving
religious
socially conservative
folk southern folk who had
a a real
deep-seated belief and yearning for
and faith in education
and they are people who
were and are great parents
what did they do though i mean here
you're three kids in the family
three kids in the family all with law
degrees yes
all graduates of princeton yes you've
rhodes scholar
all that how'd that all happen well they
created
a very loving family
they created an intensely loving family
they created a family that
told the kids that they were dearly
loved no matter what
they also told the family the kids to be
ambitious
and to go out into the world and do what
you want to do
they were not people who stood over us
every minute
they they did have one rule which i
think is a great rule they did have a
rule that said to the kids
especially once we turned 11 or 12
you have to be interested in something
you have to have a particular passion
frankly
we don't care what that passion is but
you have to have a passion
so for my older brother actually for all
three kids tennis became a passion
and their their idea was that they they
didn't want to stand over us every
minute of the day
they wanted us to do something
where we would in a sense
discipline ourselves and so
all three kids play tennis
my younger sister was very interested in
music
uh my older brother before he became a
tennis player was a swimmer
but we all had to do something to sort
of wrap our lives up into a discipline
and for me it was tennis for a long time
and then school took over
but how i mean let's go back over the
pedigree saint albans
princeton rhodes scholar yale law school
now teaching at harvard
it takes more than love to get through
all that what did you do well
my parents made sure that um one thing i
should add but
my parents never made a lot of money and
one of those when i look back one of the
most extraordinary things about all this
they sent us to very elite schools they
were expensive schools
um but uh through
their saving money they were very frugal
people they pay for all that
no they didn't pay for all they they
always paid i mean these schools there
was there was never
a a a free ride uh they paid to the
extent that they could pay
and uh they all we we we were
scholarship kids
to a large degree when did you know that
you had this
talent to learn and and to do well in
school
well um for for a good long time i had
trouble in school
when i went to um when i went to saint
albans
it was it was it was not all peaches and
cream
um i um
i was especially in math at saint albans
i
i needed help and they gave me help
i i had some difficulties there
but i got over those difficulties
there if there was one my parents
were always on the lookout for putting
us around
um good people they always made sure
that we were around good people so
my church was a place that they were
excellent people i remember my ministers
were very important to me there was one
in particular
reverend frank williams who was very
important to me he was a great
uh great minister gave great sermons and
uh that that
that meant something to me that those
sermons went deep into me
at saint albans there was a there were a
number of just great teachers
foremost among them for me um
was a gentleman by the name of john f
mccune
he was a history teacher he introduced
me to history
and um the lessons i learned
through john f mccune have stayed with
me the historians he introduced me to
steven
woodward richard hofstadter um
james mcpherson at princeton who became
but who was by the way my brother's
thesis advisor and was my thesis
thesis advisor these were people
that wrote books that made a difference
for me
i remember the history book
that i read as a 10th grader at saint
albans that history book um
it was r.r r.r palmer
and joel colton's a history of the
western world
is a book that i still own and
that stayed with me and
i think that my teachers and my parents
had gave me books i was always around
books
they gave me a sense of possibility and
they sort of encouraged me they gave me
a lot of encouragement
hanging in your office is a i understand
a photograph of
lily armstrong yes why louis armstrong
is one of my heroes
let me here's here's a person who
um you know was sort of
born in the grip of deprivation
who became one of the
um a great of american culture
and uh his uh
virtuosity uh was an ins
is an inspiration to me and also his
attitude
here's a here's a man who
could have been bitter and there was a
lot for a lot for him to be bitter about
was not bitter smile on his face
optimistic
was had a sort of a can do
attitude and um
was open to new experiences
open to the world was never intimidated
royalty didn't intimidate him
presidents didn't intimidate him uh he
was a person who felt very comfortable
in his own skin
those are among the reasons that the
louis armstrong is one of my heroes
what would thurgood marshall emanuel
clerk for at the supreme court think of
this book
thurgood marshall would really like this
book why uh
thurgood marshall would like the book
because
uh thurgood marshall
was a person who
i think was very open
to the wide range
that is the story of african americans
uh american life he knew that the story
of african americans is a uh is a varied
story it's a story that's full of
paradox it's a story that's full of
irony
thurgood marshall by the way i might add
is a person
who loved jokes told lots of jokes
and a very appreciable number of those
jokes
figured in a very in an appreciable
number of those jokes the word [ __ ]
figured very prominently
the subtitle of your book today the one
that people can buy is the strange
career of a troublesome
word originally the subtitle
plan for this book was to be a problem
in american culture and if you look at
this book up close
and you can see what would happen if you
put right under the word
a problem in the american culture why
did you change it and whose idea was it
to change
well i think that the fear was that if
you just had
[ __ ] a problem in american culture it
might sound like a document put out by
the uh
you know klu klux klan i think there was
a there was a feeling that that might be
misunderstood
um and so uh my
um it was
it was it was sort of a joint
decision made by myself my editor errol
mcdonald
and his colleagues at pantheon books
near the end we always knew [ __ ] was
going to be
the title that there was there was no
two ways about the first time it's
happened either no it's not the first
time it's happened i think people have
often have forgotten that there have
been any number of books where
[ __ ] has figured into the title in
fact i did a
search of the harvard library
uh for titles where [ __ ] appears
and they're they're hundreds if you
include
uh short stories poems plays
um so it's this is this is not the first
um but to go back to your to the point
we
we didn't know what the subtitle would
be until very late
in the production of the book and
finally we thought uh
errol and i that that this particular
subtitle
would would probably be the best one who
decided that the cover would be black
the people at pantheon books i didn't
they sent me
the cover and asked me what did i think
of it
actually it's subtle if you can see it
on the screen there it's it's actually
brown in here and then black around the
edges
they sent that cover to me and said uh
what do you think
and i said it looks like uh
a very uh catchy
uh cover that uh
i think alerts uh
consumers to uh to to what this book is
about tell a story about the coach
story about the coach is one of the most
interesting stories in the book
there was a coach at central
michigan university uh
coach dan brock
who was coaching a basketball team
the basketball team was
mainly black there were some there were
some white guys on the team
but it was mainly black team and at half
time they were losing
a game so they come into the locker room
at halftime
and coach danbrought really wants to put
a fire under these guys
and so he says the guys listen uh you
all use
a term at in your practices the n word
and i really want to talk with you all
can i use the n word they
they nod and say yeah and so he says
listen um
we're losing out there you're not
playing with enough intensity you're not
playing with enough heart
you guys need to play like [ __ ] out
there now the way
and the reason why he said that was
because he noticed
that the players would use the word
[ __ ] and when they used the word
[ __ ]
they meant when you were playing like a
[ __ ] that meant that you were playing
with intensity you were playing with
heart and so he was saying to them i
want you to play with that in you know i
want you to play with intensity and so
then he goes around and he say he points
to people
in fact he points to one of the white
players and he says you know to
whatever the white player's name was so
and so here is playing like a [ __ ]
then he plays one of the black players
and he says so and so here is playing
like a [ __ ] and then he points to the
others
he says but you guys aren't they go out
and they play the second half by the way
they lose they lose the game
go back to the campus and there was a
player who had actually been cut from
the team a black player who had been cut
from the team
who learns about this episode in the
locker room
this player writes a letter to the
school authorities
complaining about the coach's use of
[ __ ]
at halftime the
athletic director pulls the coach aside
and says
listen don't ever use that word again i
mean if you use that word again you'll
be fired
and so the coach coach dan broad says
okay fine i won't use the word again
uh he thinks that that's the end of the
story but
it's not there's publicity about the
fact that this guy this coach used the
the word [ __ ] their demonstrations
the demonstrations lead to more
publicity there are lawmakers in
michigan who talk about maybe yanking
funding from the university unless
something happens to this coach
initially the coach was told that i was
told that uh
he would have to take an unpaid leave
uh or you know take some sort of they
would there would be some sort of fine
initially
uh he was also told that he would have
to
have a sort of a counseling session with
the uh
with the team
and he he acquiesces to all of that
uh but then ultimately that's not enough
ultimately he's drummed out of his job
ultimately he's
fired when he's fired
uh he sues the school
asserting his first amendment rights
and interestingly enough the team sues
the school he was fired on the grounds
that his use of
[ __ ] had violated the school's
speech code
the irony is that the team
wins their suit the team attacks the
speech code
and a united states district judge
agrees with the team says
the speech code is in violation of the
united states constitution so the speech
code
is invalidated however for
legal reasons that we needn't get into
here coach dambrot
loses his suit and so he is
thrown out of his job um
that is the long and short of
that story what interested me about this
the story
is not so much the legal wrangling but
really the politics of the story
because um uh i was interested
in the the sort of this this irony here
are the black players the black players
i
might add rallied around coach
danbrought and in fact when he left when
he was thrown out of his job a number of
the black players
left the school a number of black
coaches
rallied around dan brought in fact
one coach wrote an affidavit
saying that indeed dan brought was right
that he had black players that used
[ __ ] in precisely the same way that he
had used
[ __ ] in this way and talking with the
students
so you had this this this scenario where
there were some whites and blacks who
wanted to get rid of coach dan brought
there were some whites and blacks who
rallied around coach dan brought but you
had this tremendous controversy
you also told a story early about the
1944 incident at the national cathedral
yes and what's the point now that was a
a harrowing story of a um
of a murder um
that was a case in which a
white woman uh
called a black
janitor a [ __ ]
the janitor
ended uh it's unclear because we only
have the janitor's story
ultimately but according to the janitor
he he he
um uh initially
hit the woman sort of just sort of
reflexively
and he ended up killing her he ended up
strangling her death
and because of her use of this word
[ __ ]
and that's what triggered it he
was represented by a great attorney he
was represented
by uh the the the killer was represented
by
charles hamilton houston a great
attorney one of the great attorneys in
american history he was charles hamilton
houston was thurgood marshall's teacher
and was at one point the leader of the
litigation at the naacp one of the great
attorneys in american history
in the event houston made the argument
that
this word had such was so
provocative that it essentially made his
client uh sort of um
just it drove his client insane
essentially
for a few minutes it it provoked him
what what houston tried to do was to use
a sort of a variant of the
of the doctrine of provocation to try to
diminish the culpability
of his client he was not trying to get
his client off entirely he was simply
trying to save his client
from execution because at that time
anybody who was convicted of first
degree murder in the district of
columbia
was automatically executed
and this case by the way led to a
supreme court decision
and the supreme court ultimately held
against
houston's client and the man was
ultimately executed
but houston argued that this particular
word
with this particular client given his
upbringing
given all the baggage of [ __ ] in the
black community
was sufficient to trigger the uh
a doctrine that should diminish the
culpability
of his client one of the reasons why i
was attracted
or prompted to write this book was that
particular case and by the way i came
across a number of other cases
there was a case decided in the district
of columbia
just a few years ago a fellow got an
altercation two black men got an
altercation
one of the black men called another of
the black men [ __ ]
um the guy who was the target
of the of the of the slur shot the other
fella
and tried to get the his culpability
reduced
using the idea of using the doctrine of
uh of provocation
the um the court of appeals of the
district of columbia said no
in the district of columbia we still go
by the just
words doctrine which holds that
mere words mere words smear words
doctrine mere words are not enough
to diminish someone's culpability uh for
a violent assault uh so
again that's with this last controversy
the controversy with
the the janitor at the national
cathedral
these are just one of hundreds of
of controversies triggered by the use of
the word [ __ ]
and of course people shouldn't forget
about the o.j simpson case
probably the most famous criminal trial
in american history
the word [ __ ] figure prominently in
that case and there are hundreds of
cases like it
we're out of time if you want more
you're going to have to read this book
this is the cover our guess has been
randall kennedy thank you very much
thank you very much